joe biden reportedly begins the
evacuation of ukraine plus members of
the central left are beginning to wake
up to the covid control scam but the
public health bureaucracy can't let go
i'm benchmare this is the bench shapiro
show
today's show is sponsored by
expressivevpn thousands of my listeners
have already secured their internet join
them at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first remember that you're
spending way too much money with your
current cell phone provider plus they're
probably giving some of your money in
donations to some of the politicians you
really despise this is true for verizon
att t-mobile they support people like
joe biden or nancy pelosi or chuck
schumer and that leftist agenda but here
is a solution for you pure talk see pure
talk uses the exact same towers as one
of the big guys same 5g network as one
of those companies but with the peace of
mind that you are supporting a veteran
run business a business whose employees
are right here in the united states so
yes this is one monthly bill that you
can be proud to pay and you will be
saving about half of what your current
cell phone bill currently is because the
average family saves over 800 a year so
head on over to puretalk.com find the
plan that's right for you find the phone
that's right for you or just bring your
own and then because they love the ben
shapiro show listeners enter promo code
ben shapiro and you will save 50 off
your very first month that is
puretalk.com promo code ben shapiro
again puretalk.com promo code ben
shapiro and save 50 off your first month
and save hundreds of dollars down the
road puretalk.com promo code ben shapiro
alrighty so joe biden's poll numbers are
just absolutely abysmal they continue to
be abysmal even a new fox news poll that
shows joe biden up at 47 percent
in terms of approval rating still finds
that about 60 percent of americans don't
want him to run again 52 disapprove of
his handling of covid only 46 percent
approve 58 disapprove of joe biden on
the economy 54 disapprove of him on
foreign policy on border security 59
disapprove only 37 percent approve
and asked
who they would vote for if the 2024
presidential election were held today
only 36 said they would vote for joe
biden 60
said they would definitely or probably
vote for someone else these are abysmal
numbers for the current president of the
united states by the way kamala harris's
numbers are no better she is at 43
approval rating
and right now the survey asks about
generic congressional ballot if the
election for congress were held today
who they would vote for republicans
narrowly edge out the democrats 44 to 43
but that really means because people
don't like saying that they are going to
vote for the republican party is the
republicans in a wipeout
this this poll by the way is actually
one of the stronger polls for joe biden
of of recent measure a lot of the other
polls have them down in the mid to low
30s
and the media are beginning to catch on
to this chuck todd over at nbc news he
says that joe biden is no longer seen as
competent or effective yeah no joke
there
president biden's news conference on
wednesday was designed to kick off a
second year reset of his presidency
cap recaptures political identity if you
will but our our new nbc news poll
suggests mr biden does need a reset
because he's lost his identity a bit
he's no longer seen as competent and
effective
he's no longer seen as a good
commander-in-chief or perhaps most
damaging as easygoing and likable in
fact just five percent of adults say mr
biden has performed better than expected
as president
okay when chuck todd is off the biden
train that train is just derailed
there's no one left on the train it is
off the tracks like in the fugitive
harrison ford is running away from it
and is going right into a ravine and it
is it is a bad situation for the body
administration the only funny part about
that quote from from chuck todd is that
he thinks that joe biden was ever seen
as radically competent or effective
hussein is not donald trump but that is
not the same thing as being seen as
competent or effective meanwhile over on
cbs they're having the same experience
they had a focus group participants were
asked whether they think that america is
better off for the last year under joe
biden it went very very poorly again for
joe biden in this cbs focus
group during the course of the pandemic
we've been listening to americans
through zoom to get their thoughts on
covid the economy and how the government
is handling it all on friday we checked
back in with six of them
who feels like we are in a better place
now than we were a year ago show of
hands
[Music]
no one believes we're in a better spot
now
well that's not great for joe biden
meanwhile the person who's coming under
fire because somebody needs to come
under fire for this if you're the biden
administration someone has to go under
that bus the person who's being
criticized most often is ron clayne ron
clayne is the current white house chief
of staff they're actually a couple of
them he is the radical chief of staff he
spends all day on twitter and for all
the talk about how trump was constantly
on twitter ron klain is just a twitter
devotee he spends all day long just
retweeting allies of president biden and
trying to tweet his way through it it's
become sort of an internet meme when joe
biden has a bad day which these days is
every single day ron claim has to tweet
his way through it he just has to spend
his days trying to get through that well
howie kurtz reported over on fox news
that joe biden is now offering to do
interviews on behalf of ron claim that
is always a very bad sign for you when
things are going so badly that your boss
is having to come out and say that he
has your back
and your boss is the president of the
united states that is that means you are
doing a terrible job so here's how he
kurt's reporting this one
ron clay knew based on my reporting when
he took this job that this day would
come uh that he knew that the low poll
numbers and the voting rights defeat
would make him a target he kind of looks
at his like being an nfl coach where you
turn on talk radio everyone's talking
about uh all the stupid things that you
did and he's consulted with former
chiefs of staff i can report that
president biden has seen this coverage
that he's backing his top aide and he's
offered to do interviews on claims
behalf okay that's hysterically funny
first of all it's bad politics if one of
your advisors has become the face of
your failure and you have the ability as
president of the united states to take
that person out of the rotation and then
to say listen we'll keep ron around
because we still think he has valuable
advice to offer but we've decided to
shift directions
i mean if joe biden wishes to save his
presidency he needs to make moves like
actually moving ron clayne out of
position of influence instead ron clain
is still online tweeting like right now
he just retweeted for example benji
sarlin benji sarlin is a reporter over
at nbc news of course he's the policy
editor and uh he retweeted a tweet from
benji sarland and ron clayne
in which starlin quoted joe biden saying
to the us conference of mayors that they
would increase funding for the cobs and
sarland tweeted this is the latest in a
long series biden is actually saying the
thing pundits constantly say he should
and it probably doesn't matter all that
much and ron clan is tweeting that
because the thing is that ron twain a
client doesn't actually want joe biden
to tweet or say these moderate things
right ron clayne wants him to say the
radical thing but there is joe biden
trying to defend ron clayne which is
a power move from a guy who is in the
mid-30s in terms of approval ratings
according to half the polls meanwhile
gensake is trying to quiet the base one
of the big problems for the democrats is
a lot of democrats are off the biden
train jensaki told him over the weekend
you know go have a margarita go for a
spin
the the cultural bubble in which these
folks live is truly incredible that they
think that the vast majority of their
patrons are people who have margaritas
and go to kickboxing class here's here
is jen zaki
my advice to everyone out there who's
frustrated sad angry pissed off feel
those emotions go to a kickboxing class
have a margarita do whatever you need to
do this weekend and then wake up on
monday morning we gotta keep fighting
okay um i'm just gonna point out the
vast majority of people who follow
politics in the united states are not
single women who live on the set of sex
in the city have a margarita and go to a
kickboxing like what is it what does she
think people do on the weekends it's it
is such a bubble well here is the thing
when it comes to domestic policy the
president of the united states does not
have plenary authority right joe biden
has been stifled in his attempts to pass
for example bill back better because
kristen cinema and joe manchin are
willing to kill the filibuster he's been
stifled in his attempt to rejigger the
entire american voting system because
again he can't kill the filibuster the
president of the united states is
checked by the supreme court so the vax
mandate gets struck down by the supreme
court of the united states he's checked
by the legislature if they decide not to
fund him he can't do the things he wants
to do there's one area where the
president of the united states does have
extraordinary authority which means that
you really can't judge the success of a
presidency by the stuff that he can do
it's very difficult to judge a president
by the stuff he can't do right the stuff
that joe biden has already done on
domestic policy has been a disaster area
and whether it is inflating the currency
via his massive spending binges or
whether it is his failed attempts to
crack down on covid by essentially
restricting blue states while red states
go about their business
oh that's been a failure but again not
all domestic failure can be based on on
the president of the united states
because the president of the united
states is not the only player in this
space however on foreign policy he
basically is the commander-in-chief of
the armed forces has almost unlimited
authority on foreign policy especially
because the legislature has over the
course of the last several generations
completely abdicated its own authority
if you read the constitution of the
united states it says that you are
supposed to go to congress for a
declaration of war we have not actually
had a declaration of war in this country
like a full-scale declaration of war
since world war ii and there's the gulf
of tonkin resolution that gave the
president of the united states the
authority to do certain military actions
there was the the aumf the authorization
for use of military force in 2002 with
regard to afghanistan which was not a
full-scale declaration of war we do not
have declarations of war in this country
to the point where in the early 1970s
the congress of the united states passed
something called the war powers act
which said that the president of the
united states because he needs to
sometimes get involved in foreign
conflicts he has to come inform us
within 60 days and we have to decide
whether we wish to continue
greenlighting this thing but the reality
is that over the course of the last half
century or three quarters of a century
nearly all foreign policy power has
moved over from the legislative branch
to the executive branch it used to be
split it is no longer split which means
that what happens on foreign policy is
100 squarely in the lap of the president
of the united states and this is the
part of trump's record that never gets
commented upon because this part of his
record was actually quite good if you
look at donald trump's record with
regard to the middle east he actually
had breakthrough peace agreements for
the first time in a generation and a
half donald trump's record on china was
much stronger than his predecessor
barack obama's donald trump's record on
russia by the way was much stronger than
barack obama's record on russia
all the media could say is that donald
trump was a tool of vladimir putin which
made it very weird that vladimir putin
did not surren did not invade
surrounding areas during trump's
presidency
you'll remember that he invaded crimea
while barack obama was president of the
united states and he invaded georgia
while george w bush was president of the
united states and he didn't really
invade anywhere so far as i can recall
while donald trump was president of the
united states so the supposed kremlin
tool was was actually not that good of a
kremlin tool
but joe biden has been an excellent
kremlin tool and a tool of the chinese
here's the thing about foreign policy
very often people think on foreign
policy that it basically comes down to
where are we willing to put american
troops and we shouldn't be willing to
put american troops anywhere that is not
basically american territory that if
anywhere on earth gets attacked and the
united states is not directly implicated
this means we have no interest this is
not how foreign policy works the reason
foreign policy does not work this way is
because foreign policy is largely a game
of trying to look five ten years down
the road and see who your enemies are
and to thwart their ambitions because
you don't want to fight them when
they're big you want to fight them when
they're small
this has always been a part of american
foreign policy and if you look at the
history of american foreign policy when
the united states goes to sleep bad
things happen
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that you already have your helix sleep
mattress right i know you do because
i've been talking about it for a very
very long time but you don't just need a
mattress you need couches in your home
and this is why i am pumped that helix
has now gone beyond the bedroom and
started making sofas they just launched
a new company it's called all form
they're making premium customizable
sofas and chairs shipped directly to
your door so what makes an all form sofa
really cool for starters it's the
easiest way you can customize the sofa
using premium materials at a fraction of
the cost of traditional sores you can
pick your fabric it is spill stain
scratch resistant the sofa color the
color of the legs sofa size and shape
make sure it is perfect for you and your
home
they have arm chairs and love seats all
the way up to an eight seat sectional so
there is something for everyone you can
always start small and buy more seats
later on if you want your all-form sofa
to grow and change with you when you
move all form sofas are also delivered
directly to your door in the past if you
wanted to order a sofa you would need to
hire someone to come and assemble it in
your home or break your back trying to
put it together yourself
all form has simple quick assembly no
tools necessary i have in all forms so
if i picked out the three seat sofa with
chase and the sand color with espresso
legs it is super comfortable it is the
preferred napping spot of the shapiro
clan if getting a sofa without trying it
in store sounds a little risky you don't
need to worry you get 100 days to decide
if you want to keep it that is more than
three months if you don't love it
they'll pick it up for free and give you
a full refund they also have a forever
warranty literally for all time all form
is offering 20 off all orders for our
listeners at
ben find that perfect sofa at
allform.com
ben okay so when it comes to american
foreign policy if you look at the
history of american foreign policy
whenever we go to sleep something really
bad happens so in at the very end of
world war one for example a fight broke
out you'll recall in russia between the
reds and the whites and the united
states and britain actually put a very
small contingent of troops in northern
russia in order to help the white
russians who were sort of the the
less communist russians led by a man
named alexander korenski they were
trying to help the white russians fight
back against the predations of the
bolsheviks and there was very little
domestic support in either the united
states or britain for this and so the
west essentially abandoned russia to its
fate and for the next 70 years russia
was
the scourge of the west the soviet union
basically
led to the the creation of world war ii
there's a very good book out right now
called stalin's war talking about how
world war ii was it's largely perceived
as only hitler's war it really wasn't it
was also manipulated by stalin
and bottom line is this preventative
action is a lot cheaper than fighting
giant world wars the united states
slashed its military between world war
one and world war ii to the point where
by world war ii the united states is
military ranked 19th in the world in
military strength just below that of the
philippines
it turns out that that was an invitation
to aggression by the japanese in the
east and by the germans in the west
right the same thing happens over and
over and over whenever the united states
cuts its defense america's enemies take
advantage of this this happened during
the 1990s when the united states cut its
defenses believing that the cold war was
over and it was time to retrench al
qaeda got very strong and started
striking out at american targets
culminating in 9 11.
so it's all fun and games it's very easy
to talk about the post-vietnam syndrome
and this belief that america's military
should not intervene anywhere on earth
the problem is that our enemies don't
have exactly the same sorts of concerns
our enemies don't care in fact our
enemies look at a weak united states on
the global stage and they start getting
aggressive
and essentially they're like hans gruber
in in die hard remember hans gruber the
the criminal in die hard there's a scene
where he is talking on the walkie-talkie
with john mcclane and he's threatening
to execute
one of the
one of the hostages and he says to he
finally does execute one of the hostages
and then he says to john mclean
eventually i will guess to somebody you
do care about and this is true with
america's enemies eventually they will
get to something we care about they
already moved on hong kong a couple of
years ago and nobody in the west batted
an eye because the united states and
britain they basically surrendered hong
kong the minute in the late 90s they
decided to transition power over to the
chinese hong kong was eventually going
to become
an
essentially just a pawn of the chinese
government at that point everybody knew
it but they wanted to pretend that the
chinese government was somehow
trustworthy which is insane and now you
have the chinese who are threatening the
australians in the south and they are
threatening taiwan and in fact there's a
story out today
that the chinese just flew another 39
warplanes toward taiwan and their
largest display of power in the new year
continuing a pattern that caused the
island to scramble its own jets in
response the formation of 39 jets on
sunday night according to sky news
included 24 j-16 fighter jets and 10
j-10 jets among other support and
electronic warfare aircraft according to
taiwan's defense ministry taiwan's air
force tracked the people's liberation
army planes on its air defense radar
systems it added chinese pilots have
been flying toward taiwan on a near
daily basis during the past year and a
half since taiwan's government started
publishing the data the larger sortie
was 56 warplanes on a single day last
october
the activity has generally been in the
airspace southwest of taiwan this is the
air defense identification zone or
airspace it monitors out of national
security considerations
and
this particular action came a day after
the united states and japanese navies
put on a show of force in the philippine
sea it included two u.s navy aircraft
carriers two american amphibious assault
ships and a japanese helicopter
destroyer
so tensions have been ratcheting up and
the reason the tensions have been
ratching up pretty obviously is because
joe biden is an idiot and decided to
with no reason whatsoever pull out of
afghanistan leaving the entire country
to the rotations of the taliban by the
way they're still americans who are
stuck behind enemy lines over there the
state department has been happy talking
this thing and pretending that everybody
who wanted to get out got out that is
not true there are at least 100
americans who are still stuck behind
enemy lines they can't find their way
out because as it turns out they're
basically being held hostage by the
taliban why should the taliban let them
out the taliban is in control of the
country 19 million people are probably
well 19 million women are living under
the absolute sex slavery of the taliban
regime and millions of people will
probably die over the course of this
winter and this is the talk from the
united nations this is all on joe biden
remember joe biden has plenary authority
over foreign policy pulling out of
afghanistan surrendering in afghanistan
to the taliban directly and you can get
a delay
by the way there are new documents
demonstrating that joe biden was warned
months in advance that this is precisely
what was going to happen if we
completely undercut the air support that
we were providing for the afghan
national government everybody knew that
he didn't care he wanted to get out by
september 11th he did 13 american
service people were murdered on the way
out hundreds of americans were caught
behind enemy lines and afghans were
falling off american wheel wells we flew
planes out of afghanistan and now the
entire country is in control of the
tower so if you're russia what do you do
if you're russia the first thing you do
is you look at joe biden and you realize
that he is a weak need scrawny thing of
a president and you run directly over
him and that is precisely what is
happening in ukraine right now so joe
biden again
happy talk is not a strategy happy talk
is a coping mechanism so here is joe
biden trying to happy talk his way
through the disaster in ukraine he says
we are now positioned better globally
than we have been in a very long time if
by better he means significantly worse
then i suppose that's true
as a result of the progress we've made
record economic growth record job growth
faster economic recovery than any other
nation on earth
we are better positioned globally than
we have been in a long long time
no we definitely definitely definitely
are not we 100 or not
okay so
joe biden announced over the weekend
that the united states would begin
evacuations in ukraine
so it'll be great like every few months
here under this administration we can
have a fall of saigon moments in which a
helicopter takes off from the top of an
embassy according to the associated
press the state department on sunday
ordered the families of all american
personnel at the u.s embassy in ukraine
to leave the country amid heightened
fears of a russian invasion the
department told the dependents of
staffers at the u.s embassy in kiev that
they must leave the country it also said
that non-central embassy staff could
leave ukraine at government expense the
move came amid rising tensions about
russia's military buildup on the ukraine
border that were not eased during talks
on friday between secretary of state
anthony blinken and russian foreign
minister sergey lavrov in geneva
state department officials stressed the
kiev embassy will remain open and that
the announcement does not constitute an
evacuation the move had been under
consideration for some time it does not
reflect an easing of u.s support for
ukraine said the official that's weird
because joe biden said literally last
week that if vladimir putin walks across
the border and starts to carve out minor
incursions he won't do anything
prompting vladimir zelinsky the current
president of ukraine to say there are no
there's no such thing as a minor
incursion into the sovereign territory
of a nation which of course is true
by the way the state department
announcing this doesn't constitute an
evacuation does not mean it's not an
evacuation why are people leaving if
it's not an evacuation do you normally
just leave your place of work
is that is that a thing you typically do
in the absence of any danger if your
boss says i need you to leave your
workplace right now go home immediately
don't worry it's not evacuation i just
need you to go home because there are
people who are about to march across the
border wearing different uniforms that
sound like an evacuation to you because
that is textbook dictionary definition
evacuation in a state department
statement they noted recent reports that
russia was planning significant military
action against ukraine however the
russian foreign ministry has accused
nato countries of escalating tensions
around uk ukraine with disinformation
which of course is insane nobody
actually wants some sort of conflict
with russia the russians
use this information as a regular tool
of what they do when it comes to foreign
policy
the state department added quote the
security conditions particularly along
ukraine's borders in russia occupied
crimea and in russia controlled eastern
ukraine are unpredictable and can
deteriorate with little notice
demonstrations which have turned violent
at times regularly occur throughout
ukraine including in kiev
also the department issued a travel
advisory they said do not travel to
ukraine due to the increased threat of
russian military action and covet 19 and
copen 19.
ah the state department it's not that
vladimir putin is a threatening invasion
of the country you might have to worry
about omicron guys exercise increased
caution in ukraine due to crime and
civil unrest some areas have increased
risk the travel advisory for russia was
also changed and uh they also blamed the
situation ukraine plus kovid19 the
all-purpose cover for we suck at our
jobs by the way the state department is
now openly advising people quote given
that the president has said military
action by russia could come at any time
the us government will not be in a
position to evacuate u.s citizens so u.s
citizens currently present
so u.s citizens currently present in
ukraine should plan accordingly arrange
commercial flights
arrange commercial flights
yeah this is going to go well so yeah
forget i mean we'll leave you there and
uh figure out your own way home grab
yourself a jet blue seat it'll be fine
probably there's some open wheel wells
if you if you really need to get out
there's some wheel wells attached to our
planes you know hold on as long as you
can
this administration is a bleep show it
is a bleep show
and everyone knows it in a second we'll
get to joe biden's new proposed response
first let's talk about timing the market
it can be a dangerous game you don't
know when it's going to go up you don't
know when it's going to go down one
thing i think is going to happen
everybody knows is going to happen
because the federal reserve's already
announced it they're going to start
tapering when that happens mortgage
rates are very very likely to rise the
latest forecasts project a few interest
rate hikes this year alone the first
increase could come in the next month
which means now is a great time to call
american financing take advantage of a
free no obligation mortgage review where
you'll learn about custom loan options
that can save you up to a thousand bucks
a month from lower rates to shorter
terms even debt consolidation they can
do it all and they never charge upfront
or hidden fees so why not see what they
can do for you if you like what you hear
you can pre-qualify for free and
possibly skip two mortgage payments plus
you may close in as fast as 10 days just
call
that is 866-721-3300
721 3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net mls 1-8233 for mls
consumer access dot org go check them
out right now 866 721 3300 that is 866
721 3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net to get started
with that mortgage refi right now okay
so
now joe biden is considering deploying
thousands of troops to eastern europe
and the baltics this should have been
done months ago it should have been done
months ago joe biden became president in
january 2021 and proceeded to do pretty
much nothing
pretty much nothing
here's the thing about deterrence
deterrence only works when you have
credible threat of the use of force that
threat is only credible when one of two
things is true either you have tripwires
everywhere meaning that if somebody
stumbles across the tripwire bad things
happen this is why we have american
forces still present in south korea for
example it doesn't rely on the american
president to make a statement that if
north korea crosses the border into
south korea the u.s will get involved we
have american troops directly in harm's
way so if they do that
if they cross that border americans will
die and the united states president and
congress will basically be obligated to
get involved it's that simple there are
two things you can do you can do that
the tripwire system or you have to have
a president who is so intimidating that
everyone just knows
that if you cross him he will break you
does joe biden sound like that kind of
precedent so we didn't have the trip
wires and we also have a weakling for a
president and russia knows this so too
little too late the united states is
trying to pour resources into the region
as a deterrent again the goal of putting
troops in eastern europe is not because
you want to go to war with russia it's
because you don't want to go to war with
russia
it turns out a great strategy for
getting yourself into a war in europe an
excellent strategy for getting yourself
into a war is to keep surrendering
chunks of land to an autocratic regime
we have a fairly long history of this in
europe and as it turns out all over the
globe
surrender is not actually a strategy
surrender is a strategy for emboldening
your enemies they move on to the next
thing that they want deterrence is an
excellent strategy for getting people to
back off and the way you get them to
back off is either you are very
intimidating as a human or two you've
put a bunch of tripwires all over the
place joe biden did none of that so now
he's trying to backfill this so he's
simultaneously weak by evacuating all
the embassies in ukraine and by getting
americans out and then by telling
everybody hey find yourself a commercial
flight and at the same time i'm going to
backfill sanctions i'm going to backfill
putting troops in eastern europe if
you're vladimir putin now the now the
anti has been up to the point where you
almost can't afford for domestic
political reasons not to cross that
border if putin doesn't do it now now
looks like he's been backed down by
biden
so this is why the biden administration
pretty openly thinks that putin's going
to cross that border at some point in
the very near future
according to the new york times
president biden is considering deploying
several thousand us troops as well as
warships and aircraft and nato allies in
the baltics in eastern europe an
expansion of american military
involvement in mounting fears of a
russian incursion into ukraine according
to administration officials the move
would signal a major pivot for the biden
administration which up until recently
was taking a restrained stance on
ukraine out of fear of provoking russia
into invading but as president putin has
been ramping up his threatening actions
towards ukraine and talks between
american and russian officials have
failed to discourage him the
administration is now moving away from
its do not provoke strategy in a meeting
on saturday at camp david the
presidential retreat in maryland senior
pentagon officials presented biden with
many options that would shift america's
military assets much closer to putin's
doorstep the options include sending 1
000 to 5 000 troops to eastern european
countries with the potential to increase
that number 10 fold if things
deteriorate
the officials spoke on the condition of
anonymity because they were not
authorized to talk publicly about
internal deliberations biden is expected
to make a decision as early as this week
they said he is weighing the build-up as
russia has escalated its medicine
posture against ukraine including
amassing more than 100 000 troops in
weaponry on the border and stationing
russian forces in belarus on saturday
britain accused moscow of developing
plans to install a pro-russia leader in
ukraine so anthony blinken talked about
this over the weekend he said there are
two paths for russia diplomacy or
massive consequences
we've given russia two paths there's a
path of diplomacy and dialogue one that
i engaged in with foreign minister
lavrov
just last week in geneva but there's
also a path of its renewed aggression
and massive consequences that we have
been building now for many weeks
okay so does anyone actually think that
there will be massive consequences the
russians don't think that they think
this is all a bluff because why wouldn't
they think that
what biden is really talking about doing
here is putting a bunch of troops in
nato obligated countries
and nato currently has 30 members the
member countries include places like all
the places that we're talking about
bulgaria estonia latvia lithuania
romania slovakia slovenia albania
croatia right all these places are
members of nato ukraine is not a member
of nato so putin wanted to guarantee
that they would never become a member of
of nato because ukraine had been making
pro-western moves over the course of the
last couple of decades to separate
itself from russia russia doesn't want
that to happen and so they've been
trying to dissuade the west from
allowing those sorts of moves now there
really isn't an act of nato application
on the board from ukraine so really what
this is is just an empty threat said
vladimir putin has a pretext to invade
the country and just claw it back when
you have a failing regime internally
which is what russia is russia is not
even a second rate power really is a
third rate power at this point in time
it's only major resources natural gas
that it's exporting out to europe but
other than that it has a completely
failed economy run by oligarchs
so what do you do if you're vladimir
putin you have to get aggressive on your
borders it really is the only choice
okay well putting
a bunch of troops in nato countries
isn't going to scare putin about ukraine
right all it's going to do is it means
that he doesn't right now invade latvia
lithuania estonia bulgaria right the
actual nato members because that would
provoke a response but nato is quite
fractured over what to do here and
that's the fault not just of joe biden
but the europeans
the this is in europe right i mean the
united states is in the united states
last time i checked a map and europe is
in europe and if europe can't get its
act together that makes it very
difficult for the united states to take
strong action in places like ukraine
none of the military options being
considered include deploying additional
troops to ukraine itself biden has made
clear he is loathed to enter another
conflict following america's painful
exit from afghanistan so really what is
this it's a bunch of military posturing
in countries that are not ukraine well
we surrender ukraine to vladimir putin
who will consolidate the territory and
then he will abide his time but here's
the thing there are other countries on
earth that are looking with hungry eyes
at other surrounding territories there's
a reason that china is performing
military exercises in increased fashion
over taiwan if you're china do you wait
until there's another president
really if you want to do something about
taiwan do you wait until there's another
president or you just make the move
you have like a million more men than
women in china you have an
extraordinarily powerful military you
know that there will be heavy costs to
invading taiwan but you also know that
the united states is not going to allow
itself to be drawn directly into a
conflict over taiwan
so if you're looking at joe biden who is
a weakling what stops you exactly
and this is the thing about foreign
policy again when it comes to foreign
policy it is not about ukraine it is not
about taiwan it's about what they take
next because eventually they will be
consolidating power and they will come
after something you do care about by the
way we should care about taiwan
considering that semiconductors are
largely produced in taiwan
that if you actually want the stuff
in your home to work you actually need
those semiconductors okay like th this
is something there's a point that the
historian neil ferguson has made he said
the next war you know resources in the
past resource wars have been fought over
things like oil and fought over coal if
you go back historically but the new
resource war is technology
and a lot of that technology is censored
in border areas
where our enemies are very very
aggressive
now again the bite administration trying
to happy talk its way through this
john kirby of the pentagon he says well
you know if russia does invade ukraine
and won't have many friends well i'm
sure that's going to scare the living
tower out of
vladimir putin i'm sure he's just up
nights about his friendship circle
if in fact they commit another incursion
into ukrainian territory they're just
going to set themselves up for even more
isolation from the rest of the
international community this is not a
country that has a whole lot of friends
this is not a country that has allies
and partners to lean on the way we do uh
the way the west does
okay so we will see if there is any
strength enough to to dissuade
putin from walking across the border in
the meantime
it is being reported that vladimir
putin's actual plan here is to keep
taking pieces and pieces and pieces and
then trying to install a pro-russia
leader in ukraine so this is what the uk
has been reporting anthony blink and the
secretary of state echoed that message
over the weekend
let's start with that new british
intelligence that the russian government
is planning to install a pro-russian
leader in ukraine does the u.s agree
with that view
well dana i can't comment on specific
pieces of intelligence but you know
we've been warning about just this kind
of tactic uh for weeks uh and we've
we've spoken to that publicly and just
last week we sanctioned four agents of
russia uh ukrainians uh in ukraine uh
seeking to destabilize the government so
this is very much part of the russian
toolkit it runs the gamut from a large
conventional uh incursion or invasion of
ukraine to
these kind of destabilizing activities
in an attempt to topple the government
now again all of this coming
coming from russia is a direct result of
perceived weakness in the west
it is that simple that's that's what
this really is about
and that is an astonishing thing it's an
astonishing thing it didn't have to be
this way
if you're a ukraine and you spent
hundreds of thousands of dollars paying
hunter biden and all you got was this
crappy russian t-shirt you should be
pissed as well if you drop bags of cash
with the biden family and all you get
for your trouble is vladimir putin on
your doorstep knocking and joe biden
evacuating personnel while putting
troops in belarus yeah man that that is
it that is a raw deal for you if you are
ukraine again if you're taiwan see this
is the thing
the more of these sorts of incursions
that happen the more of this that
happens the more you will get a better
chance of pro-america's enemies regimes
being installed in these places because
let's say you're taiwan and you know
that if it really comes down to it the
west is not going to help you
the west is re-arming you to the extent
that they can raise the cost for for
china incrementally but they're really
not going to do anything in the end if
china wishes to take taiwan china will
take taiwan and the west has made it
clear they will do nothing i mean that's
what happened over hong kong if you know
that then at a certain point the
population is going to say is it really
worth it what if we just became friendly
with chinese
this is precisely what happened in hong
kong i mean they actually did a reagan
election they pretended that they won
they didn't really win why wouldn't the
same thing happen in ukraine why
wouldn't you have some of the the bad
old guys come back in the yanukovych is
the world come back in at the behest of
vladimir putin and take over the country
again
the the problem is that now we are at
the point
where we are close to put up our shut up
time
so
it never should have gotten to this
point it never should have gotten to
this point this is the outgrowth of the
grand strategy of the biden
administration which is to retrench on
foreign policy that strategy has been a
massive failure and we are just a year
into this garbage administration already
in just one second we'll get to the
latest on kovid so
the reports are out omicron has
basically ended the pandemic
okay this is according to the who the wh
show literally put out a report in the
new york times today saying that omicron
because it has hit a huge number of
people and is killing very few of those
people on an infection fatality rate
basis
that the pandemic is coming to an end
our public health bureaucracy cannot
will not let it go we'll get to that in
a moment first if you're spending too
much money on gas i have a solution for
you and there's no question that you are
spending too much money on gas by the
way because who isn't i mean the gas
prices are crazy right now you need get
upside my listeners are making up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas every time
they fill up just download that free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code shapiro
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents cash
back do not pay full price at the pump
anymore get cash back using get upside
just download the app for free use promo
code shapiro get up to 50 cents per
gallon cashback on your very first tank
of gas some people who drive along are
making as much as two to 300 bucks a
year in cash back there is no cash the
cash back is added directly to your
account you can cash out anytime it's
your bank account paypal or an e-gift
card for amazon and other brands just
download that free get upside app today
use promo code shapiro get up to 50
cents per gallon cash back on your very
first tank of gas again use promo code
shapiro when you download that free get
upside app get 50 cents per gallon cash
back on the first tank and then 25 cents
per gallon on every tank after that
alrighty
so if you haven't already go check out
our new comedy series truth yeller it's
hosted by comedian and podcaster adam
carolla over at dailywire.com
watch the next episode airs this
thursday and adam gets controversial he
goes after hunter biden and the way our
overlords are attempting to crate train
your kids tj miller of silicon valley
deadpool big hero 6 and more joins adam
to drop some comedy gold and proves he
knows how to identify a grandma killer
so head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code miller for 25 off
your membership look out for the new
episode with tj miller dropping this
thursday you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so meanwhile joe biden's handling of the
pandemic has been disastrous mainly
because they just refused to acknowledge
the reality which is that the pandemic
for the vast majority of people is over
and when i say it is over i don't mean
that omicron isn't killing people it is
killing some people i'm not saying that
omicron isn't hitting people it's
hitting nearly everybody what i mean is
that how you choose to react to omicron
is up to you and it is up to your local
politicians and your state politicians
and your federal politicians so barry
weiss of uh of former new york times
fame and sub stack fame barry weiss was
on bill maher's show over the weekend
and barry made the perfectly obvious
point that she hangs out with liberals
all day which she does she lives in a
very blue area barry is is not
conservative she is an anti-radical left
liberal sort of andrew sullivan mode uh
sort of in the mode of some of the
members of the intellectual dark web and
barry weiss
she came out and she said this pandemic
policy will be remembered as a
catastrophic moral failure
you will realize most importantly that
this is going to be remembered by the
younger generation as a catastrophic
moral crime
the city of flint michigan which is 80
percent i think minority students has
just announced indefinite virtual
schooling in the past two years we've
seen among young girls a 51 increase in
self-harm people are killing themselves
they are anxious they are depressed they
are lonely
that is why we need to end it more than
any inconvenience that it's been to the
rest of us
okay she was right about this now
hilariously there are some people on the
right who are very critical of barry
because the outpouring was very
pro-berry online
okay here's the thing guys take your
allies where you can get them it doesn't
mean that folks who have been
center-left on this issue have been
right the whole pandemic they have not
been people who were left at the
beginning of the pandemic and were
suggesting that we needed to lock down
interminably and then particularly
people who were left after the vaccines
were available who've been following the
fouches of the world got it wrong the
enti nearly the entire time they got it
wrong okay but
now that the worm is turning don't start
saying that it's bad for people to join
the club it is good for people to join
the club of course this policy has been
massively destructive and must never be
allowed to happen again but here is the
thing the public health bureaucracy will
not allow it to stop they won't allow to
stop now down here in florida things
have been normal for what a year a year
and a half like people have been acting
like normal for a year and a half
particularly if you are young and
healthy people have just been going out
and living their lives
for if you were 20 years old and healthy
in florida the pandemic lasted for about
three weeks me in terms of your personal
behavior right the first three weeks you
were freaked out and then you realized
it was hitting a bunch of old people and
you were like okay if i don't hang out
with old people and i hang out with my
friends i'm fine okay that was the
mentality in florida and then once the
vaccines were available the mentality
was i'm done we are finished i remember
last passover there was
basically a fairly open unmasked party
you know now that was like march of last
year because the vaccines were now
widely available to everyone and
everyone felt safe because they should
feel safe because the vaccines were
effective in preventing hospitalization
and death we are now like almost a year
past that almost a year past that
and still the left will not let go only
in blue areas now i'm just amazed by
this i told you last week about a paul
krugman column in the new york times in
which he was talking about how you know
it's because of red state failures to
abide by our strictures that omicron
continues and it's like dude what's
slowing down the country is you what is
slowing down the country is coveted
paranoia according to the wall street
journal quote schools may be open but
they're struggling but here's the thing
i kind of noticed that this is relegated
mostly to blue areas
here's what they say schools should be
open pandemic or not much of the public
says if only they all had what they need
to function students in new york city's
elite brooklyn technical high school
played hangman in psychology class
recently while a substitute sat behind
the teacher's desk
they were eager to prepare for a coming
meds from exam but their usual
instructor was out sick again
everyone's kind of freaking out said
delia marcus 17 we haven't really
learned anything the fast spreading
omicron variants of coven 19 has dealt a
fresh pandemic blow to brooklyn tech one
of the nation's largest high schools
with more than 5 800 students and among
the most competitive with an admission
rate under 10
the problem there and in many other
schools boils down to a mismatch between
demand and supply while many officials
and parents nationwide push to keep kids
in schools and away from remote learning
omicron has left many schools short of
the essentials needed to operate like
teachers substitutes bus drivers
cafeteria workers and sometimes students
themselves
teachers say they struggle to teach in
classrooms while also delivering remote
lessons to students who can't attend
because they tested positive or were
near someone who did and yet the left
can't let it go they just cannot so
kathy hokel up in new york she's still
defending mass mandates for kids based
on nothing based on zero things it's
crazy here she is
i know people are tired but i also say
one thing about the kids
my daughter had a meltdown over having
to put sneakers on to go to kindergarten
she got used to wearing sneakers in
school they just
they adapt better than adults do and
i'm really proud of the parents who made
sure that their kids understood this is
for their safety and got it done
okay this is insane i'm sorry kids do
not adjust better than adults do to
things like wearing masks
and if they do is because they have now
imbibed the insanity from their parents
and their grandparents i don't know what
kind of society sacrifices the future
and the current welfare of their
children on behalf of the 80 year olds i
don't know what kind of society does
that to prevent to pretend that it is
the kids who are the danger to a society
where everyone is now having omicron
unmassed and the kids are the least
vulnerable is totally crazy
but again the public health bureaucracy
can't let go because to let go would be
to acknowledge that they got it wrong in
the first place so you still have
anthony fauci out there i don't know why
he's still out there he's still saying
don't get overconfident why is anyone
listening to this dunderhead why he's
been wrong every step of this pandemic
it's amazing
ultimately they're all going to go in
the same direction there may be
a bit more pain and suffering with
hospitalizations
in those areas of the country that have
not been fully vaccinated or have not
gotten boosters but we do know and that
these are the recent data that have come
out from the cdc
that even with omicron boosting makes a
major major difference in protecting you
from hospitalization and severe outcomes
so things are looking good we don't want
to get over confident but they'll look
like they're going in the right
direction right now
we don't want to get over confident we
never want to get over competent we
can't get overconfident i mean like what
in the hell what you couldn't control
this thing the entire time i can't get
overconfident meanwhile biden's cdc
director is still telling people that
fully vaccinated now means boosted
that's what it means just endless by the
way you know what the number one country
on planet earth right now in terms of
per capita omicron cases is israel where
everyone is like boosted eight times
in israel 80 of your body weight is now
the vaccine here's joe biden's cdc
director trying to say that fully
vaccinated is now boosted it doesn't
matter if you like me had two doses
plus omicrons i now have natural
immunity
none of that matters
by the way i think i had omicron i
didn't test positive for it to be fair
although some of my family did anyway
here we go
right now we're pivoting our language we
really want to make sure people are up
to date that means if you recently got
your second dose you're not eligible for
a booster you're up to date if you are
eligible for a booster and you haven't
gotten it you're not up to date and you
need to get your booster in order to be
up to date
they're just crazy they're just crazy
meanwhile they're doing nothing by the
way to actually get the coveted pills
that people need in place right the
therapy how is it that we've known for
several months at this point that there
are therapeutics available that lower
the rate of hospitalization death by
like 90 to 100 percent this would be
pfizer's pax levitt
why why is it that that has has we still
have like 200 000 doses available for a
country in three of 330 million like
this is nuts
again the failures on the governmental
level are astonishing and continuing but
we are supposed to believe them even
though everyone has basically gone back
to normal in their daily lives in the
same areas of the country so get the
left should they get as pissed at barry
weiss and bill maher as they want but
the reality is that barry and bill have
it right because we had it right before
barry built it alrighty we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content
in the meantime go check out the michael
knowles show that is available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wydowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high event audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
christina production assistant jessica
crand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
a democrat politician pulls his own bill
to help pregnant women after
accidentally admitting that pro-lifers
are right the cdc changes the meaning of
fully vaccinated and a government
meeting in alaska begins with an
invocation by a satanist check it out on
the michael knowles show